thank you to Harry's and expressvpn for
sponsoring more on them after the
reaction citizens of the reject Nation
we are back at it it's only my second
watch of the year I'm very excited how
are you John I am very excited as well
we're getting spooky and we're getting
comic Booky it's both of our Vibes two
things we enjoy two great taste to taste
great together very excited to dive into
30 Days of Night a comic I enjoy quite a
bit excited to see if I enjoy the movie
quite a bit did you enjoy the movie
quite a bit leave a comment below and
let us know you enjoyed the movie quite
a bit or not so much a bit in fact now
you good lovely leave a like that'll
encourage us to know that you like what
we're doing as well as liking the movie
the comment is for the movie The like is
for us spiritually retroactively and
appropriately you also hit that
subscribe so we know that you want to
keep watching stuff and get
notifications for other things we are
watching again it's a conversation of
communication about the love of movies
and us and finally if you want to become
a patron head on over there and you can
watch full watch along sync up with your
own copy to watch it front back
beginning to end the entire experience
including our resting watching
phases they get a lot of stuff including
exclusive watches with John and Greg
that only happen over there on the
patreon so subscribe like other things
and a very special thanks to the fine
folks at prepper for prepping this very
video for editing it for making it all
spicy for making us look even better
than we already do that I believe is
everything sew everything Co there's a
new I'm I'm G give you guys behind the
scenes this is gonna get edited out but
in case it's still here there's a whole
new sheet here and it's intimidating cuz
it's like five points but when it's
written out it feels like so much more I
did I did I didn't enjoy it but I did
okay all right good lovelies it's time
for 30 Days of Night in three two
[Music]
one oh I ghost house look out know they
still making stuff I think so oh Dark
Horse comic like the mask the mask was a
Dark Horse comic man knows new Kevin
Smith Comics Dark Horse Quick Stop
Comics ritten by Kevin Smith over Dark
Horse look out northernmost town in the
US
OFA couldn't live there tell you right
now I haven't even seen the movie yet I
would not live 80 miles outside of
anything I am a city boy you don't want
to be cut off every winter for days of
the title it's it's even ominous if you
don't know their vampire in this movie
like just the idea of 30 days a night no
than you've seen insomnia it's already a
horror no thank you B Foster I adore
this man one of my favorite actors he's
so good and he looks like he does in
that Bruce Willis
movie
oh the last Voyage of the
demer if Ben Foster was in it I would
have seen that
too did you see deer no me neither All
Right audience the last Voyage of the me
neither oh
man could tell this is going to be a
frolicking good time oh yes my man is
frolicking right
now where does the sky begin just that
hood makes him look
otherworldly yeah the lockoff shots
awesome cuz his head's the only thing
like slightly moving in the frame yeah
oh my
God no Outpost 31 music is intense this
score is unnerving some Norwegian guys
is about to run up and tell the plot of
the whole movie
yes oh good oh let's do this it's when I
like to arrive to towns this is a really
pretentious way of saying that it's
Sunday last day of sun until
tomorrow
my there he is who' do something like
this maybe someone a little upset about
their roaming
charges stealing satellite phones Mak
sense you can Hawk them oh yeah they got
to be valuable around here but burning
them youngsters pulling some prank
definitely arson youngsters they left a
note you to their parents for the world
or whatever not a bad idea though man
it's got a point wowe that is beautiful
yeah yeah the last sunset for three
days better appreciate this while you
can I'd visit for that and then like
Boogie you know not not stay with the 30
days a night Peggy here on our first
date Peggy yeah we all did we all
brought Peggy here Peggy not Peggy of
course my man they knew they knew my man
I can't imagine filming in these
conditions how do the cameras survive
that cold like things like that I know
they have special Rigs and stuff we went
to panav Vision one time and the guy was
telling me about the camera they used to
shoot the gray and that was like out an
actual freaking blizzard so yeah so yeah
they do have special rigs for this
stuff North Slope burrow one of the five
burrows the Beasty Boys did a whole
album about the north slow bur I want
the Alaskan Beasty Boys
album why do you even bother with that
nobody's going to see it for a month
it's tradition
he I like this guy I hope he doesn't die
[Music]
horribly okay he's got the inhaler it's
come in handy later wow it changes from
563 to 152 cuz everybody's getting the
hell out of Dodge I would but man kind
of put this off till the last minute
didn't you it's a lot of small towns in
this state my boss wants all gear
inspected and certified by the 31st you
got this Miley you sure you don't want
to stay me and Genie were kind of hoping
that you and eban might rethink this
separation thing become a quadruple with
us notice you're from across the bar we
like your Vibe got to make the plane he
already changed the number on the sign I
can't stay he'd have to change it again
it's going to be very dark it be a 153
and frankly have fun in Seattle yeah so
long C call when I get there the sun
barely comes out there
either you will hardly notice less
disorienting they only go slightly
different yeah
yeah ah it's like the thing it's like
the thing I really like the plot
exposition of just changing the signs
you know how many people are in the town
how much of a thing it is people leave
like that's really clever in one
[Music]
scene no crywolf
no
what okay not a fan snuff interlude not
a fan of the violence and
puppies this for generators yeah yeah
mostly oh boy I'm going to have to site
you for it I can't even leak it all over
the street yeah don't eat the black snow
hey it's this guy Fast and Furious in
Batman's Zone I don't like f that you
don't you don't have to site
me don't have to do anything isn't that
why we live out here you know for a
little Freedom jeez yeah be away from
from all Society my Bow's not so bad
why'd you bother riding him up why'd you
burn him he lives all alone out there in
the South Ridge a little citation now
and then lets him know he's a part of
this
town I I like your reasoning C's great
in this script really works for him
something bad happened
togs uh oh John Reese doggies folks
you're listening to kbrw Barrow Alaska
today's the last day today what a last
day and you are
not
[Music]
who oh what a clever way to trap her in
town reluctantly but what happened you
are not making that
plane hey Stella are you
okay the brakes jammed then it's going
to ring me to the
airport would an EV my mom could come
down and give you a toe but you know she
don't move too fast get her down here in
the snow
hey
Stella should be the ringtone I mean
obviously come on
EST I need I need a ride to the airport
you in town and you didn't want to talk
I had fire marer work here a I'm stuck
on Ransom at 355 and the airport will
close and I'll never get to Anchorage
get the anchors out of your pants man I
mean if you want to talk we can do it on
the
drive you want to talk Stella stuck at
and Ransom at 355 she needs to ride to
the airport you go get
her with the talk I mean that's that's
saying everything you needs to
hear that's beautiful that is stars on
the
ground beautiful it's like the thing it
is what would do this every kennel every
dog we had what are we going to eat for
the winter did you fight with anyone
recently John I'll kill them this wasn't
done long ago I'll find them it's crack
detective work try your brother Evan do
you want to play I can't right now J oh
come on man lighten up while you were
busy with John ree Carter Wilson called
about a vandalism
problem Point Hope and Wayne Right see
if they have any
troubles feel like that shot was
supposed to go on longer yeah that sful
face looked very poignant to go yeah had
something else to say
there
he wanted her stuck you just signed her
death warrant other cup yeah or at least
her injured warrant there'll be someone
you can bunk with no don't start Billy
and Peggy and me we can put two girls in
one room got a place you own two girls
one room I got bills to putting the mail
my plants will die it'll work out of
course the price is stay in my place
explain to me and Peggy just what the
heck is wrong with you and
Ean that's what this is really about we
got to fix their ship
oh man's got a family I'm worried can't
your wife bring you up a sweater or two
to mom bring the whole tribe up while
she's at it I'll come when they're ready
I guess I've found all kinds of garbage
in here over the
years sometimes I can yank them out
before the muffin monster chews him to
[__] the muffin monster the muffin
monster the muffin monster who lives
under a real does he know the Muffin
monster I saw Wilson's helicopter logo
pull that stuff out for totally trashed
uh I put it in dry duck when the
tourists headed south I haven't looked
at it for days they ripped out the
throttle the rotors have theing
helicopter
sheepers why would someone rip the hell
out of my
bird someone's getting eaten by that oh
yeah evil dies tonight they're doing
such a good job building tension and the
sound design every time it gets ominous
then they spike it yeah very much
enjoying the mood it does have thing
vibe sure
definitely it's also interestingly
textured like I don't know what it was
shot on I think it was digital but like
there's some really interesting depth of
field and like this guy's stubbled and
stuff like everyone's got like a grit
definite contrast and the comic super
contrasty oh yeah mhm stay safe out
there
Brimley catch the
beus
be it's almost black and white because
the setting which is cool
yeah oh yeah it's like black and white
with blue tinting yeah I think he's
going to be the first to eat it or get
[Music]
[Applause]
eaten oh no there more than one oh yeah
Circ oh
damn who are you
[Applause]
people oh Jesus right to the diner you
know that's what they were doing Moon's
over my
hammy no whiskey no wrong oh is it your
boy yeah he's back just bring me a bowl
of raw hamburger can only get meat too
two ways around
here Frozen
burnt Frozen thank you that's enough pal
leave the lady be got a very interesting
delivery what a scary take taking the
outside I would like to see that
oh
too nice job you have to clean up after
Ean kicked your ass that was awesome
it's more trouble than you Earth
yeah couple that lays down the
W wrong person to leap
at stay
down so hot when you pin people to the
bar at the diner fire Marshall's office
let you carry one of those things funny
thing I never
asked just walk in and grab the gun
that's how I put fires out where you
going to stay
do this over him I wish Ben Foster did
more he does like a movie a year and I
miss him look maybe I'll I'll come along
and and say hi to Jake and
Helen he must need a lot of downtime
between the roles that he takes I can't
even imagine shaking Off the Darkness
yeah the intensity and just like
[Music]
napping oh man the smells you can tell
he exudes
yeah it's like every shot of him he just
looks more disheveled yeah the costume
production designer great work on Ben
Foster's aromatics yes let's head back
to my place neither of you are getting
me alone a sure right none of us have to
be greedy a come on sheepers is this the
girl with the sunset rock paper scissors
whoever wins we go to his place this is
the way to settle this on three
oh no I knew it was coming and I still
wasn't ready nope distracted us with
Flights of
Fancy
Gabe Gabe
Gabe every's got white teeth in this
movie oh oh
Gabriel the red is so vibrant against
the white
yeah you don't work at the ref iny you
didn't fly in somebody to seen you or
did he and you're definitely not from
around here how'd you get in 80 Mi ain't
close we got a long time to figure this
out nobody's coming for you for a
month counting on
that look at them teeth they're like
reshaped for grossness there's like a
pointing what the hell is that oh it's
pot just as weeded as cop desk didn't
tell you I got a little Greenhouse at
home didn't want you arresting me what
no why you want to go live with Grandma
no I just thought you and Stella ought
to have some privacy that worked
out good kiddo tried oh he knows they're
here the phones OH police stations are a
classic place to get eviscerated
so helpless against what is coming no
that accent I'll check on Gus check on
Gus B the windows try to
hide they're coming it's time they going
to take me with them h of Me All of Me
who are
they let's
go oh he's so good in this he's so
creepy
God he looks like Michael Sheen's messed
up brother we have to stay here with him
sure we'll keep an eye him as soon as
the lines are back up get Billy over
here stay on the walkie-talkie with me
until the power's back sir yes
sir
o this would be a cool survival horror
game yeah does have video game elements
especially the transition
shots
G neither Gus no Gabe made it all the
G's are out they're going alphabetically
yes follow
it or do
that God oh nice on a pike stay in your
homes lock your doors and load your
Firearms this is not a drill yeah shit's
going down anyone with the Jenny should
go home immediately just to be safe if
you don't have one you should meet at
the diner I heard gunshots what the hell
is going on just go home I'll let you
know when I find out okay he ain't going
back you up I guess he can't he's got
the kids to look after let just have
dinner John
please come on Julia L Rus wants dinner
please oh I can't imagine
dogs
yeah it's about to get
worse oh
[__] oh my
goodness no no no no no no no no no
no nope what do you even do don't just
fire there what you even
do
oh right across the
face
Jesus
oh oh the reverse shot was great cuz we
usually see the other way yeah no one
did come help shut up ignore him
Jake you can feel it that cold ain't the
weather that's death of
approaching this guy the frame centering
him the girl thinks a gun will help her
the kid Sheriff's kid the old girl shut
up are they playing Settlers of Katan I
think so thank you for the plastic I can
snap that apart and take the lock no you
won't what don't get close with the
plastic
a
dude he
going what he going to do oh
shazbot yeah you shitthead you
sure who you here
with who are you here with whoa who did
that a gus are dead
man where are they I don't talk to dead
man like a dead man Jesus God the froth
what a great anchor of inside creepy
Billy and I work our way from South
Street to the pipeline his friends don't
have many places to hide I'll join you
except endless snow Banks and under all
the buildings that clearly lifted enough
be stupid not to take more help we got
walkie-talkies we'll be fine that's all
we
need stop the
truck what stop truck what do we got is
the more Pikes is this just everyone in
Town's head lots of heads oh I saw
something okay I had to get back in the
truck get in the
truck yeah a music cue that like just
descending
note oh D Jes Christ damn
dude
w woo
yes it's cool with the silhouette that's
so
badass jeez just going wild with the ah
the L's more approach the vampires is
amazing they look they're so
scary oh man
o gather around that for warm [__] was
that where was that where was that
no hel
oh
no y
goodie they didn't take
me wow who did they take they didn't
take me you damaged goods man did they
take my
brother finish me
up how how would you like me to go about
that
damn got a language
cool do not
turn that Danny Houston Danny Houston
yeah how did we not know about this
place 30 Days of Night with all the
night that's the writer going like we
should have made this movie a long time
ago how's no one made a movie by
vampires inas Wilson I want to go home
it's okay Dad huh it's okay oh buddy you
just keep coming how is that possible I
don't know maybe they're all cooked up
on PCP or something you know they don't
feel any bullets yeah bunch of
woids they took Aaron and Gabe he killed
my grandmother oh he hey
[Music]
kiddo Danny it confirmed oh my
God oh my
[Music]
God
whoa wow their movements are so
cool only hunger and
pain you leave Onyx the fortuitous
alone ah a playing with his
food
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
Dam I want phono
Nails woo
woo Jesus it's just Primal I don't think
152 people are going to make
it yeah we should be keeping count of
the town's people at least 20 or dead
we're at like yeah 130
something oh boy now
oh my God my ha like we don't know how
many vampires there are it's just chaos
yeah
damn this
Mayhem she looks familiar she looks like
the woman who played the nun
almost it's the opposite of most two
where there's like no lore they're just
like it's night murder Now We're Here
Jesus damn how much blood is on this
film oh oh what a shot overhead shot and
the silence just the town getting
mowed Jake oh
Broan Ean Moss backra Merry Christmas
lizards who the hell are these people
Ean what do they want we'll figure that
out when we get you guys someplace safe
all right listen up character actors
your time for Expedition will come it's
a generator at the utilidor no that's
way out on the edge of town we need some
place close to hide oh boy Charlie
kelo's attic it has a pull down ladder
you can't tell it's there he would have
boarded up his home before he left which
is exactly why it's a good idea we'll
pull down a board to get in and then
we'll tack it back sure I want you
everybody as close to the buildings as
possible if you hear anything roll under
a cross space go straight to Kel's attic
ug I'm going to load up with as many
bear traps and flers as a 4x4 can carry
yeah something's got to slow him down I
hope at one point he just comes out with
like a bear trap on a chain just like
throws it yeah in the face
yeah I'm assuming the other cop got got
in that
Massacre someone just grab
it what are we
doing
whoa oh a bunch of them oh out damn
dude
damn with the head shot oh the head to
head oh oh Jesus
Christ God
damn no not the light is it UV
[Music]
wow get out of here let's go whoa plow
again
[Applause]
not bad all right he's part of the
community
yes your leaky truck would come in
handy go go go go go go
go oh go go go go go God these high
brass tones what the hell is going on I
don't know we got to lose this thing go
where we know a place Somewhere Only We
Know
go yeah suit
up is there a raccoon up
[Music]
there my man familiar
face I'm glad they didn't blow his head
off feet on Grandma vampires you know
Jake they don't fall when you shoot them
H neither do
I my man we'll sleep in shifts we'll
ration our food and then we'll figure
out the next step so far so good we have
two advantages we know this town and we
know the cold we live here for a reason
because nobody else can
sure this movie is
[Music]
Relentless Jesus is he like your God
shut them
shoes you're not cursed to be a familiar
forever kiss me you fool
them a fascinating performance for Danny
Houston cold my dude cold that was an
extra crunchy thanks snap yes well you
know the bones are extra
brittle they're ransacking the Clark's
place they're tearing through everyone's
home we have to move yeah until they
find us and they can kill us all or we
can run like hell now some of us won't
make it but it's better than all of us
ding so maybe Denise or Lucy dies but
that's okay so long as you still have a
chance hey oh my God it's going to be
the the
Mist
stupid this guy start a fight that'll
get us all killed a lot faster yeah got
to keep [__] together we go to the
General Store we get supplies and then
we go to the utilidor but we'll never
make it there without cover we need
blankets lots of
blankets a week of night they just held
out in that for a
week somebody oh my God no they let one
out his bait oh poor
thing that's a great
shot we need to get her in here before
they find her look at the rooftops
behind
[Applause]
her it is very very immediate this movie
yeah it's like incredibly
immediate oh goody
oh those dark dead like horse eyes
yeah no I tried there isn't anybody
left please God
please jeez jez
dude
God no
God
Jesus e
oh whoa is that the
husband yeah stay put bud
have you been out here under the house
for a
[Music]
week Danny Houston just with these blank
eyes like this vacant
expression oh
[Applause]
the
man the cuts yeah the editor on this I
can kill anything I can kill these
things die in here doesn't know what
he's doing just move no we agreed to
keep the bigger weapon here with us just
move we need you here yeah man you're
the most important one of us all you're
the other cop kind
of Josh harat has an excellent Gap that
isn't quite a gap Gap yeah he's got a
cool face yeah where's Allie took Allie
couldn't follow oh you turning man my
leg hurts I know yeah you turning safe
place I'm going to pull you out yeah
this is no he's about to see his leging
well we'll get you
something oh
sh oh no sh
oh you can't shoot him you'll call
attention to
yourself oh luckily his legs messed
up oh God that's
cruel slow
[Music]
transformation
wow
wow stay back stay
back right by the swing set
oh fall right onto the
swing push him
high
oh double tap man go double tap work the
killer he didn't watch zombie land in
the words of Tony Baker there you go
work the
killer oh to chop your friend's head
off
oh it's an interesting way to play
that sound is on this
yeah gooey oh but they still show it for
funsies wowe good thing that axe was
there there's blood you can't
breathe okay I'm okay where's your
inhaler oh yeah damn it that's right
John Reese became one of them damn it
John Ree
now he knows people are still
alive tell me everything no he's going
to freak out it's going to be loud no no
dude dude what are we doing here Wilson
come on now we need to get out of here
bring your mother
too die if you go out there no no leave
me
alone what she doing poor guy feel so
bad for this guy I'm sorry
right okay remember you can't flush
we'll just open the valve afterwards I
was I was wondering about that too
they've been in here for a week where
are you guys put in the business those
houses would be stocked that makes sense
they'd have food but
man
Dad is he climbing out the window
ES
oh that's
lucky damn it Dad wait you can't just
rush out he's my father
wait you all right what happened Isaac
went to way right Wilson went to find
[Music]
him no oh [__]
and it would smell like
people I like that the blood makes like
a beard on his face goes right back to
his
ears
[Music]
oh oh
manad shout louder mhm yeah the whispery
yelling oh there you go
go
buddy yeah Bo makes my back hurt a lot
of trauma lot of stress let get get
that second act stretch
going hasn't let up for like it started
10 minutes just going yeah just
wof this looks almost like a miniature
or something whoa jeez this doesn't seem
like a good idea
but then again there are no good ideas
yeah you can't wait there a month
everybody get on that snowmobile oh this
is awful this is some of the most
effective stuff is just yeah this Ghost
Town quality it has and it does have
like an old tininess about it yeah it's
got a timelessness cuz they're so
isolated yeah the clothes are all kind
of like whenever yeah and like just the
architecture of all the little buildings
on the main strip here yeah it's modern
but very like could be anytime yeah yeah
it's like the stuff's been here for a
while the cold is so effective I feel
like the
briskness you can goods St corer propane
batteries we be back here in 2 minutes
let's go
man yes more
inhalers I thought they were cigarettes
the opposite of inhaler I was like Bro
you've got asthma smoke
oh smart counter assault get some Oreos
as well yeah get those calories
[Music]
sh God man I wonder if they did every
audition in a close-up take yeah cuz
they're all so good at eyeball acting
yeah has like hyper closeups for half
this movie yeah we haven't oh oh no oh
no no baby snake I'm done playing with
this
one e want to play with me
now Jesus Christ well I guess they can
talk oh
my wowwie that kid must have had fun on
set today just just leave quickly tell
Merill swing
away from the Blackness yeah we swing up
yeah you wouldn't think
to
whoa
yes
no no that guy yeah that
guy physical strength would be stuns the
stunts with this child I
there
oh they the little brother had to
decapitate the child they did
it it's okay I'm here for
you can feel my pulse in my
hands oh boy oh man you become a man
today my
son I could go for a crisp refreshing
Pepsi right about now now ah same man
official drink of Apocalypse oh you
don't come back from that you don't just
decapitate a child who was she I mean
does anybody recognize her they bring a
child guess that's nice it's not someone
from the town out Sil oh no that's not
nice oh boy Ean can you make it to your
station if somebody created a diversion
oh no you get bit these things can't
survive the Sun what if we brought
brought the sun
early Helen had that operation at home
she used an ultraviolet light to grow
this stuff I can run for her place let
them follow me Grandma's weed I was like
what do we have to do activate harp and
like manipulate the weather use a
satellite stop bosi doesn't mean it can
stop these things good point send that
stranger to cut us off if they can't
handle the light but if it doesn't work
well at least we tried it I hope Ben
Foster did Kill the dogs first that's
why I used a knife I'll do it of course
I'm the fastest [__] I'm the lead
character I know Grandma's house you're
15 years old forget about it I'm 15
right I'm a man now I just just
decapitated a child I can I saw you in
the back with the axe you think you're
up to doing that three or four more
times I'm going we'll see you at the
station you need to start our Jenny
first who is this Jenny everyone keeps
talking about got a star her I know I
know
generator let them comment let them them
coming oh we got a bear trap oh let's go
on his back let's get swinging I hope we
get to see a bear trap get used like
we've all wanted hey come on
mother oh the Silhouettes are so cool my
city
Screams Come
on come on buddy it's just like starting
a lawn M so cold there you
go oh man oh
God be so heavy that guyy such a beast
freaking group of them every time
they're outside I'm like it's about to
be
done yeah there we go okay that makes
sense a damn it man damn it
man
damn your your crop is not looking good
it hasn't had a made it the 18 days did
not go well there we go
yes I'd be a little gentle 30 days of
THC back here all right see if it
works what a
gamble a don't be
hasty
[Music]
he only loves you so
much yeah I've seen
her
yes eat light toasty oh not cool man not
cool
yeah yeah it
worked they're going to cut off the
power so oh oh [__] o the
immediacy Glides in
[__] God I wonder what he did to get
into character I wonder what they
discussed beforehand like who directed
this yeah I wonder it's
great going to put her out of her misery
God I'm so sorry about earlier when I
said you didn't exist I guess this is
karma or
something let's all jump into the
light o got not of acceptance
man
ahow him down damn
[Music]
dude
yes holy [__] A Child oh boss boss giant
chainsaw that might be one of the
coolest things I've seen in a horror
movie in terms of
kills yes oh he is very good at this get
them dummies
going the Trap the
Trap yeah
Dragon
oh oh fill them shells with
garlic yeah
easy that that was rad
awesome it's the wideeye melee top of
the world let's go
Bullock going to the
Winchester what a
boss oh it's okay man you did good made
your mark we Prett appreciate you take
as many dite out there yeah yeah yeah
yeah let's go
dude [__]
it oh you're
out light the
fuse light up some of that dino man yeah
oh they're flares oh they're flares for
a badass slowmo shot
yeah you a't going to eat me
respect
whoa woo damn
[Music]
dude yeu
Christy oh no not in the Town Square in
front of everybody oh I thought he got
to die his own
way you can die your
own
that's a
bar God how
unceremonious oh this is exactly what
you needed to mend your relationship
trauma lots of trauma this is trauma
therapy trauma Bond is not recommended
most cases n I'm for it soon they'll be
just five oh no and then there were
that's why he wanted to volunteer the
little girl in the store I changed just
so thirsty now let me post a thirst trap
I couldn't tell you that photo is all
I've got left of my family oh oh no I
wanted to be with them so much oh I
couldn't bring myself to do it but I
know they're waiting for me I can't live
forever oh being trapped like that when
last thing you remember oh God that's
dark God and just the light or lack
thereof on his
eyes
Carter he told us what He Wass Carter
[Music]
6 yes child I love you buckle up
oh yeah they're actually stuck here for
30 Days of Night I know somehow I didn't
expect us to go this long oh or to cross
so much time I thought they'd get to the
other place or I don't know something
else got to live up to the title that's
I mean that's
true it's
Billy son of a
[__] it's good to know Josh har and
facially hair grows like mine where it's
like 27 days maybe it's starting to be a
beard
yes that's the thing it was like it was
a week in he started to get the stubble
and now like 30 days later he's really
slowed down no it's about accurate sure
this is full grow this is not a choice I
could only have these two areas 10 years
of dedication when I shave for Halloween
it took until Christmas to come back
this Peggy and the girls I heard the
screams I didn't want them to die like
the rest whoa I tried to myself to the
gun jam
oh dude he's been living killed his
family and he's been
oh you have a family oh dude you don't
ever hurt
them
yeah ever hurt
them the editing in this movie is
violent
H where is everybody maybe they tried
for the
utilitor oh oh my God my man's is
suffering Jesus Christ I guess that's
one benefit is it is seems like a loud
place to be at all times yeah just cry
as needed get it out yeah I think the
weight of what he's done wasn't real
until he talk to people about it makes
it real yeah now the anguish I don't
trust a single child in this universe
creepy silhouette child child take out
immediately okay maybe not somehow
that's worse you see some regular little
buck teeth oh my God this kid has a body
count Gail Gail who's
Gail why does everyone in the sound have
a g
name no it was a trap no
stop they see you
Nick Cave sees you yeah with his red
right hand and left hand and
face they kept that kid for 27 days as
bait that's
wild come on man you got to have one
heroic act before you pass out it's all
you got oh no oh Dave Batista is going
to get him
first yeah he looks like Dave Batista
and David Draymond from disturb
he need little
piercings Evan why did you guys just
leave what a weird Choice y
Robins we don't know we had to eat
them you are not doing much to preserve
that now
J sure they want to stay in the shadows
makes sense and I guess it makes sense
then why they would go to such an
isolated place so does that mean they
have like a whole PR team like writing
stories and putting them out there
little misleads garlic mirrors oh
they're going to love that [__]
invitation into your
home
hello he is mastered stealth he reminds
me of somebody right now and I cannot
place he like a member of the band and
Almost Famous sure Jason Lee's guitarist
yeah or like when Samurai Jack has all
like bearded out he looks like the bass
player from Death from Above 1979 he did
he did yeah rest in peace
buddy no
[Music]
Batista
oo
ah oh oh ow across the
[Music]
face get him in
there get him in there I like that this
guy has this one fangle
tooth flip him flip him
oh
[Applause]
yeah one heroic AC no it didn't go good
it didn't oh my
God holy
[__] he's holding it that is a
mess
oh he's turning cut it off under the
elbow so there's a nice clean
break what an effect the thunk what an
effect go back I want to see how they
did that I don't I don't want to see it
ever again where was the Practical where
was the CG where where the seams where
did it all blend
in oh yeah that's that's the face of a
changed fell I got to watch Paddington
after
this I need some Spirit lifting both
Paddington after both after this at 30
days of Paddington 30 days after 30
nights without Sun I need 30 days of
Padington alternating between one and
two
BR GL I need you you want to
complain Stella whisper they're walking
around just had to hear your
voice where are you opposite the
Manan under a
wreck Jesus it' be so cold we're
freezing
Heaven yeah I can see the car the rack
on the right not to mention homie over
there there are vampires between you and
I we have to cut off or they'll hear you
I'll call you back when it's safe sun
comes up tomorrow bet your bottom dollar
oh I like that first date with the
sunset now they for Sunrise that's cute
that's cute didn't didn't predict it
good Tire
around the streets filling up with oil
what they're going to burn them
out H God they broke into the pipeline
oh that's another intense visual godamn
Jesus Christ no not the pipeline not the
already problematic ecological troubl I
love vampires care a lot about global
warming or oh [__] not to mention the
economic
implications Oh Black Gold no it's going
to literally smoke them out they're
burning down the town let's get rid of
all the
proof
Jesus not the post office that's a
government building that's all they had
nobody will know what
happened we have to tell the world
they'll just think it was some horrible
accident we got to go live next time
they'll take out Point Hope way
right ha this building's strong can't we
just ride it out
here
nah there's got to be a greater plan
here oh [__] killer of sh
she'll burn she stays of course he will
burning to death in the snow God
damn All Is
Lost the score is so
good when they're all watching me get on
the walkie-talkie and tell Stella to run
for it what are you talking about what
we doing here bud he got a turn I sure
as hell hope not when John re and Carter
change they were only bitten they stayed
who they were for a little
while dude no we can't fight them the
way that we
are what is he going to Lost Boys
he's thanks little brother a little be
take your
St oh dude you have to marry Stella now
don't do
it oh the
[Music]
needle I can watch it Carnage but
somehow this injection is no no no no no
no
no oh my god
dude oh that looks painful I can smell
your
blood and it smells good it's not a
about of confidence would have that your
first
line oh his teeth be changing
too
oh the digital artifacting on him was so
cool cuz it looked like a comic for a
few
frames wow get out of there now what a
music
cu the one who fights come and see come
and
see
oh just decked him right in the
face wow nice catch
cool ow
ow oh man Danny Houston's been doing
this a long time
yeah SP him around with a kick like a
break dance
[Music]
moment
[Applause]
ouch ow ow oh he took his tooth out
Jesus
yes sweep the leg cool do a barrel
[Music]
roll great sound design oh great sound
design
wa holy [__] punched through his head
just scold him whoa fatality oh my
God H WIS that was pretty badass right I
my fish who's next whoa just brained him
his
hand damn dude every everybody bow
down it's okay maybe the sun will rise
right now and and it'll be just the
right point in his transformation to
where it can fix it everything's fine
and he's fine he's okay now they're
going to watch the last sunrise together
and he's going to he's going to he's
going to die what did you do to yourself
man I had to had to Fight Fire with Fire
should I go after them dude hunt them
down become
BL
a you got they
Sunrise
oh hold on to the last scrap of
humanity hold on to your love true
love's
[Music]
kiss
wow
[Music]
damn
Jesus this is the most badass death
scene it's getting
dusted
[Music]
Jesus David
SL there you go oh the comic writer
wrote the screenplay not bad or was part
of writing the screenplay okay man
wow that went
hard said goes an IDW published comic
but a Darkhorse film I wonder if the
rights changed at some point man that
was could be harrowing it was I don't do
horror John I'm sorry I struggled
throughout we found the perfect
convergence my horror movies are
saxophone lead and Grandpa's
celebrate often you can't rain all the
time in them you know yeah they're
lighter thrilled to be partnering with a
brand I've been using for nearly 2 years
now and that's Harry's Razors I'm
generally more draun anything that goes
against the norm and Harry's does just
that in The Grooming World they saw the
high prices in the industry and decided
to blaze their own trail with quality
and affordability I keep a beer but
whenever you see these cheeks in the
neck clean and that's the work of
Harry's right there keeps my wife happy
and Harry's makes it effortless they're
Precision Blades that cut smoothly with
less drag making every shave satisfying
and yes it's versatile
for other areas too you know what I mean
so as a Harry's devot I can vouch for
their value you can experience
unparalleled comfort and quality in your
grooming routine for exceptional
Craftsman ship meets affordability
making a smart choice for a top- notot
shave without breaking the bank their
kits and value packs for shaving are
unbeatable but Harry's is not just about
shaving again they offer top quality
thoughtfully designed grooming products
including shampoo conditioner and
amazing body wash without the premium
price quality affordability that's a
thesis of this now these I actually
pulled right from my own bathroom I
regularly use their five blade razor
with a nice weighted handle and they're
foaming shav gel man this that oh it is
a game Cher I just like the feel of it
now I have to commit to keeping this in
my hand the whole time cuz I'm not going
to go to the bathroom in the middle of
shooting this the handles they feel
perfectly balanced and the razor Sleek
design is a classy addition to my
bathroom and the quality of the shave
unparalleled got to reiterate ke part of
my weekly grooming ritual cuz their
entire range of products fit seamlessly
into my routine definitely no re-shoot
here their German engineer blades are
durable and refill plans are economical
rarely use the word economical but I'm
using it now plus their commitment to
high customer satisfaction and no risk
trial makes Harry's a no brainer this
Gel really does feel good let me say
once more choosing Harry's means quality
and affordability by grabbing your $13
trial set for just $3 at harry's.com
reex you're not only getting a great
deal but you're also supporting this
channel that's harry.com reex for your
$3 trial set stay sharp and embrace the
extraordinary with Harry's till next
time reject Nation till next time big
thanks to expressvpn for sponsoring this
video a real game changer I've been
using for years that's right years so
whenever they want to work with us it's
an instant yes you've likely heard about
expressvpn for online privacy and
security but there's more to it than
that however there was a very real
incident recently with Spectrum showing
down my internet and contacted me due to
a suspecting hacking attempt and funny
enough I realized I hadn't actually
activated my expressvpn on my new laptop
that I got a couple of months ago so I
was paying the consequences having faced
a serious hacking issue on YouTube a
couple years ago that made expressvpn my
go-to for both security and freedom I
mean it and yes what you've heard is
true believe me this channel knows you
can use expressvpn to to watch movies
and shows on Netflix that are not
available in your country this means
accessing a vast rate of content of over
a 100 countries like a global Cinema
your fingertips it's super easy open
expressvpn switch locations refresh the
browser and there you have it whether
it's kramas on South Korean Netflix Hulu
BBC I player YouTube or more expressvpn
has you covered and it's incredibly fast
ensuring no buffering or lack for smooth
HD streaming versatile to working on not
just computers but phones media consoles
Smart TVs and more this means you can
enjoy your favorite shows on anywhere
any screen protect and elevate your
internet experience so if you want to
get access to hundreds of new shows use
my link expressvpn.com reject and you
can get an extra 3 months of expressvpn
for free that's
expressvpn.com rejects so head to
expressvpn.com reject to learn more
thank you again it's okay it's okay I
won't do this to you it's about death
stalking someone perhaps or it's a
catchy meta commentary on horror so when
people get eviscerated it's funnyish
sure sure I get you I'm discussing
scream I didn't mean to take advantage
of your trust today oh God in fact guys
look to make koi feel better if you
happen to be listening on Apple or
Spotify why don't you just leave a
rating maybe five stars koi it really
helps CO's Mor and it also helps these
uh you know podcasts and whatnot to uh
travel far and wide as we hope they
always will and buy shirts to support my
therapy bills oh shirts what do you mean
you mean like like one of these the ones
we're wearing like like this dressed in
red for the occasion exactly I dressed
with this guy who looks kind of like he
could be a vampire even though he's
based
Offa and uh and uh one from you know
squid game we got there anyway know what
that other reation shop.com that's a
great place to support the channel we
got a whole bunch of designs up there
they're designed for the most part in
house got a couple licensed things as
well but it's one of our favorite ways
to support so uh if you feel so inclined
and you want to get that reject drip all
over your physical form that's the place
to do it COI that was harrowing Manu
benette I knew that I knew I knew him
from something okay I was waiting for
the fullon credits the the credits were
great they were very ominous now we're
into the actual like read through
credits I'm exhausted uh whole thing
sound design score still carwing into my
nightmares as we speak yes keep talking
I'm I'm just make sure you're still the
point f okay I did slide around a bit in
this uh reaction there was twoing there
was frowing I did I left I came back all
uh all right so this was better than I
thought it was going to be but better as
an asterisk because I mean traumatizing
it was more affecting than I thought it
was going to be sure um only because I I
just didn't uh I don't feel like I heard
about it a lot I mean I remember when it
came out hearing a lot about it and I
remember like people loving it but I
haven't in the last 15 years heard about
it so with the quality that it was that
surprises me yeah yeah exactly it
doesn't make a lot of vampire lists you
know what I mean like when people are
like oh vampire movies like you have a
certain amount of them that they discuss
I get yeah there there are a number of
like either Classics or other like
really notable examples that I think get
brought up before this but I thought
yeah I I enjoyed this as well and I
wasn't quite I didn't know quite what
level to expect because kind of of that
sort of uh non reputation it seems to
have in both comic book and horror movie
sort of discourse and whatnot and yeah
like I I thought that this was a really
fun and immediate experience uh if I
have any complaint about it it's mostly
just that it's so
straightforward that you know there's
not really a lot of other meat on the
bones so it makes me wonder what the
comic itself was like in terms of like
what greater themes are
characterizations might have been
happening but just as like the promise
of the premise and you know being
certainly like I I I like all Stripes of
horror and I can certainly get down with
some Carnage and some gore and I thought
this certainly brought that lean mean
you know carnivorous kind of horror uh
and it had that in Spades for sure and
it had you know like the the place the
setting is a character the cold and the
contrast between the cold and like when
things are burning up and stuff like
that like all those things I thought
were really evocative and I liked the
cast a lot you know I thought they
assembled both in the characters who you
know the actors who we know quite well
as well as you know like the various
character actors and things like I
thought everybody brought a lot of
presence and where the script didn't
always have necessarily like again as
much thematically happening I thought
the actors brought tons of presence and
dedication to kind of fill in the gaps I
was behind Danny Houston at breakfast
not a week ago and now go think twice
very different experience Danny hou I
was like oh that's cool like I didn't
say hi or anything I was just I I
remember going like hey Danny Houston
and now Terror now fearce now I'm glad I
I you know reluctantly was like oh this
Danny Hugh I'll be over here because now
I'd be running I'd be leaving 2007 okay
so this was how many years ago well
it'll be 17 this year which is just a
terrifying number oh no that is too many
years since 2007 it feels like 2007 is
like five years ago I know anyway uh my
thoughts um I personally don't generally
dive into this genre um because of how
you might have experienced my visceral
reactions to things I am very affected
uh I I'd prefer to stay affected by
things I think it's it's a it's good to
have a strong fighter flight um but that
does mean like I'm I'm physically
exhausted I went to the gym this morning
before this because I was afraid this
would happen not knowing that this movie
was 60 mph to start and then accelerates
to 200 uh it starts at 60 and then it
just goes 7.5 th000 people give it four
and a half Stars I agree with those
people yeah this is solid for me um as
far as like it's like an A minus um one
of the things oh there's a sequel uh one
of the things you had mentioned was uh
you know the mean and the bone and and
those elements and I think that's one of
the strengths for me personally is I
really enjoy a nice commentary and I
really enjoy a nice like H humanity and
like those those you know uh motifs and
horror film that can make you more
introspective and all those things but I
also like when a movie is like I'm G use
Mad Max as an example like Mad Max is an
action movie that has a lot of meat on
the bone if you want to find those
things but you can also go like movie
and enjoy the bombast um this to me I'm
sure if I wanted to stop and think about
you know the Journey of what Josh Hart
and went through and like you know
separation and family and there's
there's elements that are there even if
they're not like you know as much as
part of the story but you can find that
to me I really enjoyed that this was
kind of a beat him up drag him out you
know violent for violent sake especially
maybe because I don't watch a lot of
this so this is like I'm good for a
while like this is probably my quota for
quarter one like I'm set for violence um
I I personally and I know the comments
are going to be like [__] but I don't
even like watch the Raid and [__] like I
don't even like martial arts violence um
oh the raid is so good though no no and
I I can respect it but I won't throw it
on like I you know what I mean like if I
see a fight scene and someone like is
breaking an arm not joyous for me like
just my experience of art is like if
there's trauma on screen I'm affected so
I don't like put on movies that and I
know a lot of people are like yeah hyper
violence not for me personally um but
our Serbian film reaction going I mean
obviously next week but then again like
I will watch requim for a dream often so
like it's weird like I think my exposure
to like drug trauma is different than
like physical trauma so like I have no
problem with like ass to ass like I I
can first person I have ever encountered
who has not said specifically I I don't
need to watch that movie ever again i'
probably watched requim like nine times
but I think it's good for me to be like
okay don't do as many drugs you know
what I mean like stick with mushrooms
like it's a good cautionary tale uh but
this is like you know the opposite where
it's just like I'mma beat you up with
violence and it's not my thing but I was
able to get so much out of it because it
was so like immediately it knows what it
is it doesn't let off the gas I was
worried about 40 minutes in when it had
been so brutal for so long that it
didn't knowwhere to go like my biggest
concern was like okay we've got an hour
left cuz I didn't know the run time I'm
like it's probably going to be an hour
and 30 minute movie it ended up being a
two-hour movie of just violence but I
was worried about 40 minutes in like how
are we in ending act one and we have
more to go so I was impressed that it
stayed so aggressive and stayed so
malicious like it's a mean-spirited
movie but the
mean-spiritedness doesn't always land
well for me A lot of times movies that
are being spirited I don't enjoy because
I'm like why would I why would I do that
to myself this I love that it was really
really mean but just the last 10 minutes
there's so much Beauty in that sacrifice
there's so much Beauty in their love and
like even though the movie is like screw
you it still uh it still lands in a way
that screw audience why are you enjoying
this what have you done um yeah so I got
I got a lot out of it and uh I really
liked that it was very visceral yeah I
usually don't well yeah I mean I think
that's th those are some of the greatest
strengths the movie holds and I guess
that's that's kind of where if I'm torn
on anything CU yeah like you know I I
agree I think it's it's nice to have a
movie that is immediate again that is
kind of confined to its circumstances
where we don't have to cut to like a lot
of like oh here's a flashback or
something to explain their lost
relationship like yeah I I appreciate
the the way this movie is operating most
certainly and I liked again the mood and
the characters and whatnot uh and for me
it's yeah I think as a person who
watches more of this kind of movie
specifically without you know the comic
book tie-in or whatever like this is the
kind of thing where I'm like okay cool
I've seen a number of very immediate
movies that you know kind of use their
confined circumstances as you know sort
of the whole aesthetic and and uh and so
yeah it's like if I if I crave any more
meat it's kind of just because of that
but it didn't like ruin the experience
yeah and like I your exposure to this
type of film is going to have you
seeking maybe more variety within those
parameters that you are more familiar
with whereas like this is very different
for me so I was just overwhelmed um yeah
and I love like I mean Ben Foster's
performance was insane but I love that
everyone was strong enough that you you
know you had those attachments you had
those connections you had like those
moments but the movie didn't have to
make make you want to have a backstory
like I didn't need to know any more
about Mark Boon's character yeah I
didn't I didn't either I would agree
with that it's like I don't feel like we
need to know much in terms of like yeah
like deep diveing the character because
the point is the immediacy of the
situation and I'll pick part [__] and
and other types of movies that don't do
that I'll be like okay why we could have
why didn't we and this one I was like
thank you for not yeah I think the only
thing that maybe I would have and again
I'm torn it's good because like each
point I come up with uh a counter point
of your own yeah is sort of like part of
me goes okay so the most interesting
thing about this movie The Hook of the
movie is the premise that you're stuck
in a place where the sun will not shine
will not be out you know won't be
visible from your Vantage for a whole
ass month and like that's a great setup
and then you have these vampires that
are so again feral and animalistic and
they were almost reminding me of like I
am legend or something in a way
because they have their own language and
they creatur like but they're sort of
humanoid they almost feel like halfway
between and I like these little glimpses
we got of you know you get just these
tiny little slivers of like what their
world is like and what their society is
like with a couple lines yeah and the
fact that yeah it's like oh you know we
spent so long convincing everybody that
we are you know folklore that we're the
stuff of nightmares that were not real
that were some kind of fantasy and we
can't let this get out and like that
stuff I thought was quite interesting
and you start to realize like oh okay
you know every year I guess these
vampires must migrate to another you
know isolated locked off town and and do
this again um so there were just things
about the Lord that it was making me
wonder about and then making me go damn
this seems like a unique take on
vampires themselves and now I'm torn as
to whether I want a deeper dive into
that or as to whether like it's very
effective just letting you wonder about
these things and you have Ben Foster who
is like you're like what is this guy I
guess he must just be like a familiar or
something he's called The Stranger in
the credits which I really dug cuz he
was he was just a stranger to the town
and he just like ruined lives yeah I
like that we didn't know anything like
his accent was the character development
like you know what I mean just that
drippy it was like sometimes it had
Appalachian elements sometimes it had
like it was just so it just sounded like
scary like in an unnerving way it
sounded like disconcerting no matter
what he had to say I was like ah it the
whole thing about him was off and and
yeah like what a great hook what a great
presence I really liked especially like
the mounting of everything there there
were times in the Middle where I was
like okay we're we're kind of on a
repeat cycle of like all right we're
hiding out and then we we move over here
and then we cut to Danny Houston and
he's got his vacant look thing going on
and and then he's going to do something
crazy or there's going to be like a Gore
set piece and then we're going to move
again to a simar next place yeah next
place and then we're hiding out and then
we got to move again and then and so
there were times when I would be like
okay so how how are they how are they
persisting as long I feel like the only
if I have one actual gripe it is that
they survive this month but a lot of the
survival happens through editing because
like I I don't disagree and at one point
I thought like okay day 1 through 7 is
very similar to day s through 16 or
whatever the next Mar was you cut to
like we're on the last day and and I was
bothered by that until I realized like
my back hurts like I I realized like the
IM makes up for that I didn't mind
because I would didn't want them to
interrupt that flow to give me more
because of the reaction so like the
juice was worth the squeeze that I don't
want to go back and think about like the
Nuance of what I would have done
differently CU I liked that I was like
good God yeah and I think that's the
thing is like the more wrapped up you
are in just the immediacy of the moment
I think the the better this movie plays
I like that the director looks like one
of the vampires I know he's just
straight mean mugg look at that guy's
face he's so and that's a compliment he
looks so intense and I'm like okay he
did hard candy after hard candy and this
is before Twilight eclipse what a
trajectory so he got he got his bag on
Twilight yeah and what's he been doing
since and then he's been doing did
director of Breaking Bad episode he did
a Breaking Bad episode so he's well
deserved okay so Twilight was his money
then he did Breaking Bad to to like go
back to his roots he's done a lot ofy
he's done a lot of Telly since then he
directed power two episodes of powers
that was a Brian Michael Bendis um
adaptation a comic um that was on the
PlayStation Network so it never had a
chance to do much cuz it was on a
network no one had um no this was
literally if you had PlayStation Network
you know just if you're a PSN but
literally 2015 before streaming was what
it was there was a network on the
PlayStation and this was a giant like
hundred million doll budget show that no
one got to see uh what's his name was on
it had a great cast it was um Neil Blom
Cam's guy um oh charlot toop charlot
toop dude charlot Copley charlot
copley's on a Brian Michael Bendis show
that no one saw damn crazy uh who was
the girl I think you opened up Melissa
George
yeah uh I was also going to ask just
what the com away so she's an Australian
that's like the soap oper everybody from
Australia bit of an accent yeah yeah
heat Ledger was on home and away that's
like the that's like the uh CSI of
Australia where like every actor's on an
episode of like procedurals here
everyone in Australia does home and away
I think both hensworth run home and away
hell yeah uh let's see in treatment just
Anatomy absolutely uh yeah I didn't
recognize a lot of the casts which I
also kind of enjoyed to to like all
faces you've seen but you probably
couldn't name yeah Mark Bo I love
popping up and stuff what's Manu Bennett
I know his name yeah that was driving me
nuts I was going to ask what the what
the book itself is like oh dude look up
like imagery after Manu oh that's right
he was Death Stroke yes okay oh and he
was a z yeah he was a evil guy in Lord
of the in h Hobbit AOG the defiler he's
like the main villain damn uh yeah look
up the uh comic I want you to see the
imagery It's pretty dope all right but
is it is it pretty similar in terms of
very black and white leaning um you know
there there's a lot of contrast it's got
a lot of like really aggressive Line
work um stepen Niles wrote it so it's
really cool to see that he got first
screen PR screenplay credit on this uh
okay yeah yeah I mean look at that cover
and and that's the thing too is I think
if you have the knowledge of the book
it's got to be pretty gratifying to see
the imagery brought to life the way it
is you good oh it's a web comic it's a
new one cuz even getting just like
little glimpses see that's what I'm used
to that imag here it definitely yeah it
definitely looks like those swirling
snow plumes and yeah like the shocks of
hyper aggressive Line work yeah and and
I really liked you know the the the mood
of the cinematography and the contrast
with the colors and everything and and
the blood and all that and uh and yeah
like like again I think that's I think
that we're we're we're mainly in
agreement in terms of like yeah I I
think it's like a B+ a minus uh for me
as as a movie I go like a like yeah it's
like it's there are a couple things that
could push it further into like a
territory for me but uh in terms of yeah
just like what do you expect to get from
a movie like this and and and what is
you know it trying to adapt you know I I
definitely had a good like fun Punchy
time with this I'm so tired that's why I
know I liked it because I'm like so
affected like broken and Josh haret
again we talked at the top like he is
one of those actors I think doesn't get
the credit he deserves cuz he's started
he came out of the gate with like 10
movies and like he literally was turning
down Superman within like his first two
years in La so I think that was an
element of oh this guy's everywhere and
I think people like don't like that I
think a lot of times people are like ah
this guy's too much and I know some
actors actually like people I know take
a couple years off to get out of the
Limelight so they don't like overwear
their um exposure so that way people
don't have that reaction so I feel like
Josh hartnet taking a couple years off
coming back with a Nolan film and doing
like you know a few things after that
show he did that Horror Show I think it
was really smart of him to kind of pace
his career but I've always been a huge
heartnet fan and I'm really glad like I
mean Hollywood Homicide was like his
fifth thing it was opposite Harrison
Ford like what a damn right like you
come out the gate at 20 and you're just
like by the way I'm a movie star and
like sure to do a buddy cop with
Harrison Ford like at at the out of the
jump like crazy yeah um God good for
hearten I saw him hiking once it was
good it was a good day see as tall as he
looks he is as tall as he looks at least
from my recollection yeah I can't find
out who the lady vampire was who looks
like she played the nun but anyway she
did definitely look like it also they
did a really cool job with the snake
image like the I've always thought the
uh vampires in 30 Days Night had this
very snake like Voldemort uh angular and
they did a really good job of like
replicating that yeah man see if you see
that one on the left there you scroll
down slightly uh second see yeah see
that like imagery on the left see kind
of has that energy of like the snakin
yeah go Google some 30 Days of Night
comic cells just to fill in this part of
thew sorry guys fill in the visual it's
lit page one on Google if you type 30
days of night's Comics so you'll see all
this stuff it wasn't IDW comic so it's
interesting that Darkhorse helped them
produce the film I got to look into how
that collaboration worked out yeah um
but yeah I had a really great time it's
not like an AA for me but B plus a minus
just my my experience during the film
and the acting I thought was strong as a
super immediate like exploitation film
with a comic book Vibe and a cool hook
yeah I think they they did a nice job
like yeah like I said you know they're
they way in which it could be richer for
me there are ways in which you know you
could have added maybe a little bit more
to the script to really Elevate some of
the elements of the direction or you
could have done a couple other things
with the direction to maybe make up for
those gaps but for the most part like I
said I mean you saw the reaction we were
having a blast watching this so so yeah
like when I want something lean mean and
straight to the point like yeah this is
something to reach for you know what I
just realized In This Moment the guy
that looks like Dave Batista his head
was kind of like a sharks fin hey it was
my hat my hat was the number one comment
the lit we opened that video with like
I've never seen this I only know this
song lyric and the audience was like
someh so mad that I had got the song
lyric but like why would I know if I
only know from a lyric it makes more
sense as a hat yeah but uh I'm I'm
guessing wonder if his hat sideways it's
like a fin yeah yeah yeah you know maybe
over like a
beanie he squishes the beanie vertically
it's like a shark spin guys LL
specifically if you're watching this
that's the only thing this movie needed
L Cool J would have just that's the egg
we were looking for the level up uh but
yeah this is an absolute blast let know
in the com let us know in the comments
there anything else you want us to watch
uh I personally would prefer not more
horror as you may guess that was a lot
for Force us to watch horror there's a
few comic book movies I actually haven't
seen I'm going to go through and see if
there's anything that like is coming on
an anniversary or something cuz I
realized there are like a couple like Le
certain or gentleman like things we I've
never seen never seen I've avoided it
out of respect for Sean Conor's career
cuz he chose that instead of uh
Gandalf did you know this no he didn't
want to sign on for like a t ton of
movies so his retirement instead of
doing Lord of the Rings and they were
offering him something like 10% at the
back end he would be up there with Matt
Damon if he had done Avatar as the two
most successful actors of all time and
they both turned down those roles I
can't imagine this back end an avatar
turned down by D and back in on Lord of
the Rings turned down by Sean Conor so
I've never seen lxg out of a sense of
pain uh for the Scotsman all right that
is going to do it you lovelies please
leave a comment below let us know what
role you turned down worth millions of
dollars please hit that like hit that
subscribe hit that patreon button if you
want to see this whole thing actually of
any uh video this is up there for
wanting to watch our entire experience
CU I haven't seen the edit but I will
tell you that was about two hours of
meiling this squiring reaction had a
real hard time I wonder if I left frame
points I really struggled sure all right
thank you for being here uh much love
reject Nation we'll see you next time
right here
byebye